R
POT.AS
CYOUANLS AO WCHATBO AUT BKSOO
ALIONNETIMET THAKT BOOORV.G.
THWIVS TER COV OEAGFHE T
OOIAM BAIK FR CESTIONNU NOWMI
WIIA MMIAL HERDTINV IES
E
RTREPOIE JERUL K BWNRO WHO
SESCDIUS HSERN-DEHOO LKNT IO
JTHEIEULTE EPS CINLMIRINAE. CAS
ROISTH PILAMGR W GLETND UWAERY
ORTL.Y
NA[IIBLEONVENSATRSIO]
EL>> H W ALONDCOELME TOS THI
30 EDIONTIF O THEIA MMI BKOO
FA.
IT ISY MAS PLEEURO T GETS U
TESTAR FDORHI TSNGVE ENI.
IAV HE AOU CEPL OF
CENOANUN
NTMES.
THEOO BKAIRAR CESRI ON
HOROTHUG TUTHEEA YR.
WEVEEAV ELLSNT A ORVEOW T AND
EA SVETRNDNGMI A SON O SOY STA
WOU TCH THITHE MMIIAOO BK
OFAIRHEN TEB W.
FUE,RMHEORE WEE ND TO
ACKNLEDG H TEHESDRUNED OF
VOEENTRSHA TT MEAKHI TS
AIBSSLE OAJ M SORSNSPOORPO
TTHWIOU WMHO WEOU CLD NOT R
BTHEKOOAI FR.
THE MEDIT AHNDND FOUIOATN, THE
NGREEYAM FILATOU FNDN,IO
EHAEPNI ANDTU ST,ARPENC
AUASTRTNDAN MYER OTHORPO SNS
.
LSI AOEE ND TOO DS THIVE ERY
METI,S FANF O THEK BOOAI FR.
SLET'IV GEELOU YRS AF RNDOU OF
PLAU FOR FEI BNGENRIDS OF
THOO BKAI FR.
K BEOO FRAIEE NDSRI FDSEN.
OFINDBOUT AUT THEER PKS OF
JOSGIN US A ADRI FEN OFHE T
BO
R. FOKAI
E HWEAV AAB TLETAOW DNSS.IR
WE
AV HE AOU CEPL OF
NOANNTCEUNME.S
HWE QEAVNSTUEIO ANDRSNS AWE
WHEE ERTH ENDF OHE T
PRENTAEONTI WAV HE APIN LEU
ED ANONUESTN PERTO CUSRMEO S
THATEEO PPLANET GN A
UNPOOPRTY.IT
INLLFOOW T TGHEK,ALHE TRUT AHO
WIE BT AHE TRUT AHO SNIIGNG
DE
OSKNHI TSOR FLOAS PT THE
EVEL
ORATS.
ILI WLE B ENGORSCTIER HN DOW
EREAERFTHE T TK.AL
YOURNCA PASCHEER H BKOOT A THE
OBLTAESIUTDEF O THEOO RM.
HITHWI T IIL WLDUNT IROCEUR O
MAERONER CEM FYORHI TSNI EVENG
ILOWH WRO ILNTCEDUHE T S.AKPEER
THS IAR MIA MEREY.
XEETH E DTICUVERECIRTOF O THE
LL1 BIISNIO RLOGIN GLBA
NAORCODIORRTO F,IA MMI SHEAS H
ITEDRK WH THESS ABYSCR AOS THEWO
OS.U. TERE CAT THEWA ANERESSND A
SO NRIDATYRYESECSA TO AND
NGGEAGRISTTA STIFSIC OREN GDE
CEOLVIEN.
IRIMAA ASEM MRBE OFHE TAS TK
FOE.
I-MIAMDEDA DNGOIRA TNGICFFKI
COIOITN.
[AUSLAE]
OO>> GINEVD EN A TGOLL TTHARE A
PR
TEN.
HEWHETTU VRIRRLYAL O INHI TS
RIDIAUTO.UM
AIMY VERLYRO PUDEP RINSERENTG.
THOO BKAI FR ANDHE T WEN'S
ROND FHEM T FIONDOUATN.
ETTO GHE TREHTON TIG W,EIL WL
HCUFOS OEEROW P
.ER
RPOWE OF OR'RI WTES PIAVERORBL
TN,HEOW PERF O NISCIARSSMND A
GAMIUNTIIVD TEPR AEGILE TNDHE
PO ORFNV ITITIESGAVE
LIURJONA F TSMOUSOC ATI CRILCA
IFMAGNENNGYI LSG LONND A HDAR
OOUENGH TNHEAC FTSO TPA SRK THE
TILLCOECRE OVEUT NHACESSAO T
LEGERA AIOCTN
.
IMIAMDER HALES INVVEGATITI
LIURJONAIE JSTUL K BWNRO
LELERENTLYSSSU PUREDEYEF JFR
N'STEPEIR- YSEANGLOAG ENGENEMT
LO EINXPNATITIO ANDEX S
TRGCKFIINNEM RAICKNC UHEED.
FOAD DRECEES H FREYOV ME
HUGROHHIGTYOC SIE ANDIC LYRAL
SRCCILENGEA LVI MEORND AE MOR
SIVRVORISN I HAK W.E
ERETH VONSI OF JTICE ISRY TGIN
O
UT P APO SIGTLHT ONSE THE
ESCRIMND AGT LONEIMANVO AID OCEF
EAYAN RLON CCEQUSEEN.
TNO,EG LALOT NCIIN FANORAL N
ONPERSAL.
SIT I ACI FASTINANGND A IHDEN-PT
ALOOKT THERO GHWT MIACAISRRGE
TI JOFUSCE.
IR D OTOECRF THEATOU FND
NIO
JO PLINASM,GRROAMHE THI PLA
TRC FUSESN OTINV IESNG A
MNEWSAGEOREL EXC INCLEEN
AS A WAYO T SPOUPRTNF IMEORD
COCALOL Y.UNMMIT
ANDHA TTS IT WHAS I AUTBOO T
PPHAE. HENER
PLN JSEOI MEN IMIEL WCONGER
THD ANAUIE JORUL KWN BROO T THE
I
OKI AMBO FR.AI
[AUSLAE]
I, HIE JUL.
HI EE.RYVEON
TH YKOU SO MHUC FOR CINOMG
TNITOGH.
GT'LESETEDTA SRT.
USEDO T WKOROG THEETR ATHE T
MILDHEI RA
T IM A NOTUR SEHA TTVE EONRYE
KNOWHES RY VEREL WL ANDHE TRES I
EQUIT BITN IHI TSOO BKT THA I
NELEARUT ADBO. HER
Y D'TON WETA SRT BYINEA LRN AG
BTTLILE AITUTBOOU Y.
OUEER YRO FM, HOWID D YOU GWRO
UP?
DHOWOUID YND E UP IN
JO
SMNAURLI.
NK T>>HAOU Y ALL FOROM CG,IN BY
WETH.AY
SIT IOO GD TOE B BKACN ISO PER
AT BHE FKOO
R.AI
IRE GW UPN I AIN TYOW TN CLEALD
ERSELLILSVLE.
AN YOU KW, MYOT MRHE WAS A
LESING MOMIT WHHR TEE CN.LDHIRE
NEOSSLE TAY S,E WUG STRED
QU AEIT B.
THI TNKTTLLNS ITI IEDNE M
O
OMEF THEHI TSNGT THA MY
WTHMOERTEN T.OUHRGH
IREMEMBE ONEIM TEAM CE HEOM
LLDAN A OFHE T FURTUREAS W
ERMOTHOU CLD NOTAY P UCSEY MLITY
S.BILL
JUST YOUW KNO,US INJ TCETITHA
FE SHE SDFEUFRENS ILLTIED IN
METH SUCNG YOU AGEHA TT I
OEDNT TO DOM SHIETNGUT ABO I
ATTHIN KD OFED LE MNT IONGRI WTI
R
WINITG AASNTUT OLE FOR M
WH W IASER VY YNGOU.
THT FEAC TT,HAOU YNO KW, ILD WOU
RETORI AUTBO GATREEO PEPL
N
HOD WY THERC OVEEAMCLBS OTAES
INIRHE LESIV.
IHI TNK TTHAT THAAD MEE MLS AO
ONTWA TRI WTE SRITOESBO AUT
PEE LLEIKT THA ON IOM SEAY W
AKTO ME AIF DEREFENCN ITH OER
'SOPPELE.IV LES
S Y>>OU YDITUEDR CEER IN
ADPHIL.PHELIA
WHHAAS W TTIK LE?
WHER WE YOURI WNGTI?BO AUT
WH
E WATER ROU YNGOREPTIN? O
>>RO WTEOR F ERYVEMA SLLER PAP
CYOUVELDOU E REAYGI IMA.NE
TAI STEDRT A THEMOT BTO DNGOI
UAOBITHIESRI W ACHREUA ACTYLL
VE TOO GDGINRAIND,RO GUN
AC
LYAL.
THINUT AGBO AER PNSOND AEL TL A
STTABY OUHE TMN I AER VY
RE WTFECUL.AY
T JIUSEA RYLLEN WT UPHE LDEADR
IDNHE T BNGINEGNI, IEA MN, I
O
OTDUL N SPOUPRTYS MFELN O A
SMNAURLIAL SYAR.
KE WIORD AS ATR WAIS,ESOU Y
SOWKN,TOR OFIK LEOR ACTSO, D
VISTARNGSCT AOR.
IAS W A SGRVTAIN JISRNOUAL
ORI WDKE A CPLOUE OFOB JS JTUS
AYTO PHE T RT.EN
ANHE TN IAL FINLYOT G AIG B
WHEABRK EN I WASIR HED BY THE
ADPHILPHELIAAI DLY NSEWHI WCH
WA
ASPOET MRO BTALIN,IG
ITOPTROLSP NANEWNERAP I
PHPHADILEL.IA
ENTH I MEDOVO T THEIG B CY.IT
HEND A T YNOUUAVE ENTNDYLL EED
UPN I SLOTHOU FDARI.
YE>> S.
THENOU YVE EYUANTLLT WENAC BK TO
PORTGIN.
WHON D'T YOUL TEL US AUTBOHA WT
IT TESAK BE AEP R
TEORR.
HO DWOOU Y GETOU YRRI SES.
YOTEEP RORND OSO PRI FNSOR A
MBEREAF O Y.RS
>>OUW KNO, ILW ASAYT FELIKE
OFONE HE TS WAY IOU CLDY STAN I
USISTH B WESINSASAK MEUREHA TT
I CLD D EOINRYVETH
OU CLDRN LEA A LTLITEIT BUT ABO
EV.HIYTNG
,SO IT JUSRI TEDO T BEER V
.MBNILE
SOME IINTHG,D SAI YES.ME TOO D
IKNI EWOULD BEBL AE TOEE KP
MY IOBF IKE WORDAR HDHNO EUG
AND STEV NER AUERGD.
EA LST IN THEIN BEG ONGNIF MY
IRECAER DIDOT NUE ARG A LOTND A
IDI DRY EVEINTHGHA TT IAS WD TOL
TOO.
STARRGDTE ANGUIOR ME.R IEDNC,
YAHYE,W KNO,NGUN RNI AERFT
MUNE SERCE T ISNHEST WOR
HBNEIGS HOORODIN PLPLAHIDEAHI,
INREFIS HE TIDDLF O THE
ART,GH CESRA CSH.
PRABLYTLM AOSTHVE ERYGIN I
HAON DET ANE O TEIMR O
HEANOT
T, IEA RYLLE LIKHE T,RI CME I
KALRELYDINF OOT G A NHE WHIT
NGVECORI.RI CME
ME COMRI IEA RZELID, YOU KW,NO
OLETH PEICID D NOTAY ALWSO D A
GOOB J OF IGAESNVTINGTI.
LI RIEADZEHA TT ILD COUIN FD OUT
TINTHGSTHAHE T PICOLE D NOT
EV
NOENW TND ATHAS IN WHE I GOT
LVINVO TEDOO D MEOR
IGVEINSTIVATE WKOR.
IN A>>GA, YOUAD H BNEEINOV CERG
WORISN' PNSSOND AE DONYEA RLL
PTEXCENALOR WK.
WYOUEERKI LOONGOR F SNGETOMHI
SEEL.
DWID YOUYEA RLL FDINHI TS
ORY.
RTHATLLEAYE MAD YOUAN WT TOO G
E
EREP?
SWHAT DCKHOOOU Y
?
>>OUL,EL Y KW,HI TSS I AN
STOLD YORARON CTRY TOHA WTE SOM
E
AYLEOP S
ID D NOTRE BAK THEFR JEFEY
SEISTN'.TO SRY
ITID GET A LOTF O CEEROVAG IN
AICERTCE PNLAS.
PALYULICARN PM BCHEAT A
IMETH T TETHAT IPE HAPDNE
INORIGLY.
ID DOT N GETH MUCIORA TCTN
TIONLYAL.
HII T INKTD KINF O DPPROED OFF
E
THAD RAR FHE TRERY EVEEON
LUCONCDDEHA TTEC BSEAUE HS I
WVERYLTEAHY HE GOT OFF.
S IOT N AOO GD EUGNOHEA RNSO I
FEIK LERE THEAS W MEORO T IT.
WAI ALEC EYSXPDTE TREHEAS WE SOM
ND OFPTOR CRU INIODOLNVVEN I
A.
DANHE TNN WHEDON DALRUMPAS W
TEMINONA ID,'M SRYOR, WNHE
LDDONARU TMP WASNI RUN FNGOR
PR
IDEN A WANOM HADIL FED A
UILAWS AGAST HIMND A JFREFEY
N STEPEINGAICLMIT THAE HAD H
LYXUSEALLTSS AAU HEDER ANGLO
EFTHWI JPSEYFR ESINTE AL. WEL
WAERTHE S ANRT ALEICT THA I RDEA
HEIN TAPEW NSP WERREHEHE TYER WE
O
FRT OAK TGIN THENS MAIEATRM
AMEDIO TES TTOR F NOTKI LOONG
INHI TSHO WLERY STOBO AUT
EIEPST ANNDMP TRUNDHI TSOM WAN
YOUNO KW, I HADDYLR AEA KWNNO
TOUABT CHEEASND A IHTHO TUG
OEISTH DM SSEE WRDEI.
EMAYB IUL SHODE TAK AOO LK.
IASAS W PKIICNGWA AY ATHE T
CA
RU,SE TMPADEDLE ECT INNY
DNAMITEIS HOR LABTAEC SRE
RYO
DAN I KNEWHA TTE H WAS AER PN
STHATNEIGDFF O ONHI TS
THSWEERTEALE PAEA DL TTHA
NSTEPEI RD.EIECVE
UG TIHO AHTTHE TIM TE, I WDEONR
TWHATSEHETI VIC WHOE WER
YO YG,OU KW,NO 13,4 1 YRSEA
T ADTHEIM TE, NOW TYHERE A INL
THR LEAT 2,0s IDE WONRHA WT
TTHEYNKHIBO AUT THEAC FTT THA
TYPRET LUC MHHEET TIRDA PRERTO
F OFE HKOOAS W NOW IN CRGHAE
OF AGE LAR AGEYNCH WITIGVE ORS
T
AN HONUM TKIFFRAIC ANGNDHI CLD
RLABO LSAW.
NIMY IOAALTI GL I JTUSO T TRY
TO
EE S IFHE TMSIC VTIOU WLD
FIMEY LLCORDOR FWAND AK TALO T
ME
AS ITA SED DGIIGNGOR ME AND
MONT IO THE,TO SRY I FNDOU,
NOUYO KW,HE TRE WAS SOUC MH ME
HI TSRY STO.
ICETH VMSTI,OW H TYHEER WE
TETREAD,UT B AOLSOW HTE EPSIN
GEMANA TDOIP MANATULEUS JT AUTBO
EVT PYARF OHI TSAS CE.
EDLOOKHE TTH OERAY W ASE H WAS
DO
TGIN IR OTEEL REND,
COYUAINLLIMET L HET G AYWA
TTHWI I.
E >>TH AHI TNGUTBO THETIEP ROR
TIS IYEA RLL LKEOODT AHE T
REENTIM.YS STE
UYOPE SAKUT ABOHA TT AOT L.
YOTE WROUT ABOT THA AOT LN I
BTHEK.OO
JUHE TREIF DFENT, HELD WOU
HI
OR ARETTYSNEHA TT WEERARRI
TO OERTHOR ATTYSNE ANDODOM SEB
Y
DWOULENALI EMID.TE
ASEER W CTFLONICF OESNT IERT.
PROCS.ESA LTLITE BITBO AUT THE
KUYO IW,NOGAESNVTIVETI
G,RTPOINHERES A MTEYSRYRE
AR INDT.
SYOUNTPEE TIMNGIG DGI IONT
SCORERDND AT I DSOEOT N
NEYARSSILUR TN SNGETOMHI UPR O
MEMESOTI G YSOU DONOWO T MYAN
ITRABB.OL HES
'T DYON WEET GO INT THE
ESPROCHEOFS  T WKORHA TTOU Y
D.DI
>>OUNO KW,O N O WESAK UPNE O
ADAYNDUS JTID DECESO T BEN A
IN
STIGIVEOR REPR.TE
TH AARE EOT L OFTEEP RORRS
TH
'T DATON DIK LENGOI
IGVEINSTIVATEOR WK
.
AERTHE  LOT OFTEEP ROR TRSTHAO D
T GREALIURJONASM.
WAERTHE EC ASSP OTSF,OU YNO KW,
JOURLISM IHA TTOU CLD NOTO D.
O
THAU VE YO,OUW KNO, INK THI
NG TEHIHA TTED L MEO T DO
IGVEINST JIVATEISRNOUAL IMS
USBECA IET JUSSLW AAY WTEANDO T
TGETO THE T
THRU.
ELI FTE LIKHE TRE WASO S MHUC
OINGOGNN I OUROU CRYNT AND IN
ETSOCIT TYHAIMOM SET WESEUS JT
RE
LYAL DO NOTW KNOOW HS THI
ENHAPP.ED
HIWHO TSCUAR PTI PRLASOERNED END
INHISAR PRCUTILALA PCE.
LWATTH ASAYNAAS FCIDE. M
SO, WH IENDOO LKENT IO IT,
AT
TH WS ITHA WO. D
ENHHO TUG ITS I AOT LF O
G.GGDIIN
ITO ASLS AUTBOEL TNGLI SRITOES
A
BEHAEUS T ITSHA WTES MAK
SO,T I ISIN KD OFWO TLDFO AND
YOAV HEO TD KIN OFIG DGHHR TOU
THISEN DSE, HYRIORBLOR BGIN
MEDOCUHASNT T W ATRETTRIENY B
LASER.
>>E HOUAVO TIN KDF OAK ME
SENS OUTF O I
T.
IT NSOTYEA RLLAS EY TO DOHA TT
S TINHICUAR PTI CRLAEASHE TRE
ENREWE TSF O TDSUSHOANF O
CUMEHASNT TT HEAVN BEEIL FED
TOVERHERS YEA.
EERER WE ALLF OSE THE
ERENLAWSHATSUI TE WTER
LEFID.
AKE DENOZIV CIL LS.SUAWIT
EANE O OFHE TM HAD LEIK00 2
EN
IIETRS TNHE STEYSM.
,SO IZEEA RLI A,T FIRST I
THHETGH WID IN D IT, ILD COU
HA WT I AAYLWSO DCH WHIS I
USHAYLL W ATTEEP RORROE DS.
THAK TE AIO MOTNOR F S
MY
MEJUDG.NT
A FIOOTNORRYUM SMA JTGMUDEN
TEWO DTSUMOCENHA TTOU YW KNO
H
AEYREGAY LIN OUTHE TIR CEAS
N TDHEOU Y CANRI WTE ATO SRY
FOFF OHA TT.
I DULD REAET SOMNGHI INHE T
ONMOTIUMOR F S JRYMAGMENND A
ENTH ILD WOUE B LEIKHA WT?
WH
IDEER DHE TY GETHA TT.
HEDAN TNT THA DUMENT IOU WLD
BEEIKRE THES IO NAY W I AM
CHKI PRYICNG DTSUMOCEN.
E HIAVO T RDEAVE ERYEIN SGL
INTHG.
BY DNGT THA, IAS WBL AE TO
S TKEHI ATO SRYRTPAND AUT P IT
BACKOGETHE IRN A WAYHA TT I
OTINTHK EORHE PADEPL H NOTEE BN
OLEAB TO. D
OW>> HON LGID D TTHAAK TEOU Y?
>> TOO M AD GOOEA YR AND A
HA.
>>D ROEAFLL A OHO TSE
DO
NTMES.
ETHEREREOC DENUMTST THAOU Y
NULCOD GETSCC AESO T IDHO SUL
VEHAEN MONTIED.
BUYISE TNGHEUM DOCTSENHA TT YOU
U
ISART OFHA WTS GOENT IO
THERI PCEF O THESP NEWERAP.
,YEA RLL HHSIGND AS LOW,HE TRE
S
IM TES FOR YRNGIG DGIEE DP
DANOU Y ARE NOTIN FNGDI TNGHIS,
ARERTHE EIM TESHE WREHERE ARE
OMSTJU SE.IG HHS
TELLE M,ND A THE RNGOREPTI
PRESS, TN ISHIEA YRND A A
LFHAT W,HA WAS AOMENT THA WAS
AIG B W.IN
WATWHAS A MOMENTT THAAS W
RELYIF DCUFILT?
HE>> TOS MTENHA CLLNGGIAR PTF O
TH CAS WEASDI FINNG A VICMTI
USBEE,HEOW N TE WYERN I TIRHE
2LATE.0s
MMSUIT GTEOTN M,RIAREDSTH OER
GHADEON TO JL.AI
T FIRS AOF,LLLL A OFHE TIR NESAM
D RREEA IUT OTN I THE
DO ANTMES ISFHE TYER WECU
RSMINO.
>> DOWOOU YIN FD OUTHO WHE TSE
VENME ENRE A.
YONO KW,HA WT IEDEA LRNITH
AL TOFHE ENCERXPIEE I HADT A
OIISTH P WNTAS IBLVINETAYHE WN
YO
T GUETSEHEIL FEST THARE A
EDDARECTY T,HETOR FGEO TED RTAC
GSTHIN
ACCILYNTDEALFSTIRAM NE
D IUS JT PUTET TOGRHE A BIG
ADSPRE WEESHTVEHIT EGTHRYIN I
.KNEW
WHT IAS W ALLAI SD ANDON DE, I
HA AIS LT OF0 6 WOM.EN
TAND,NHE YOUE HAV TO TO T
ACCONTM. TTHE
THAS W PYBAROBLHE TIG BSTGE
CH
ELEALNGHA TT I. HAD
ATTHOO TK A LGONIM TEDI FINNG
.THEM
THESSRO PCE OOI DNGHA TT, IN
TODEORR  FDIN TM,HE IAD H TO
THEM ATL LITE BITUT O AUTBO
AD H RZEOGECNIHED TTE PATRN
HETHWI TNG YSEOU WENOM,HA TT
LIEITHR SVEAD HN BEE
DRLYICATALEDLT AERY B WTHAAD H
EDPPHAENO TM THE.
BUETH ASEHA TTHE TYREUF SFE
KYOUW,NO AOT L OFHE TM HAD
LLFAENNT IORU DGIC ADDONTIR O
HAND EEDP UN I JL.AI
OMESOF TMHE WEERIC VMSTIF, O
NOUYO KW,ES DOMCTIBU A.SE
LD COU SEEIG RHTWA AYHA TT
THESTHE ES DEOMYEA RLLFE SUFDRE
ANOTULWF L OFAI PN.
TH SRYUS JT KDIN OFEDOR MPH
IN A, YOU KW,NOT I WAS
INORIGUSLYAL J GTNGOIO T BE A
ONACRETIO T THEOS CT OFNG BEI
NANOMID.TE
SCTVIIMAY SGINHA WTHE TYHO THTUG
B
T IT TO ME RNGLIEAZIT IAS W
A TALOT UERTT FLUAIRE ON THE
FRTPA OHE TMI CRILNATI JUSCE
EMSYSTN I ARI HOREBLAY W
YOOWKN,OU YAV HO T KDINF O
LKTA YROUDI ERTOO INTNGET LTI
YOO DOR ME.
HA>> T A WTASE.RE BEZ
EYOUR JTODIRTUSAI SD YESO T
NGYTERHI A I,M SE.UR
ETH ESIV FERI STOESST FIR.
IITS, YOU KNOW, I WAS CGEROVIN
A
CAUR HRI T INENHEID ME OF
.THIS
IT WAS QUITE --KL PARDAN
HANEDEN IHE TDL MIDE OFHI TS.
OUOF CE WRO DEDPP EINRYVETHG.
STOI DNG ALLHE T OERTHK WOR.
LIHIGHOITGH GK BNGACND ATH FOR,
ACLYAL.
INIT KD OFSCH EOEHE WN YOU BAK
AWOR F ATL LITEHI WLEND A TNHE
ACGO B TKO ITND A THE YOU
REE IZITI SLLAV HEO SH MUCO T
DE.
Y>>OUOR WKS A AAR PERTN.
T>> I TNKHITHA ELYMI ISER H
ERMESOWH
E.
ETHERS.HE S I
>>ES.
NOU CLD HOTEAV DEONS THI
OUWITHT ELYMI.
FFGIN O THEAI RLSOM S.IMETES
SYE.
PARTF OHI TS,E W DID ARUM NBE OF
DOIENTMEARHWHS IC
ER WE
RVINTEITWSIE W THHETI VICMS.
ASIT W THEOS MT INTORMPTAAR PT
TOFHEJE PRO
.CT
KNOW, IAY S NOW BAUECSEHE T
R
ST IYS NOWND ANT IONNAERTIAL
Y STOR EDANRYVEOU JTALRNIS IS
PR
LLTIACCA T OYNSHI STO.RY
I SAYHI TS ALLHE TE TIMO T ELYMI
O
ILNE O WLVE ETU CAPREHA WT
EM
APYIL CRETUD.
BEOBEUS NYOD IAR CED AUTBOE W
RE TKINGUT ABOT I FORHE T
TRSFIT IEIMN A DADECEND A THE
EMN TTRE POUDUT O OFM, THE
NO IDYSVE ER GNGOI T CTUAPRE
TTHATHE WAYT THAMI ELYID D.
OUI WOU ELDNCNYGERA ADYBO TOO G
ALIONNENDEE SHE TOC DRYENUMTA.
OSETH MTMP ITAORNT PTARF OHE T
ECPROJ
YOUAI SD,HA WT WAS THE
NTMOME YHA TTOUNO K
W.
WHE WVINT IEREDEWHE T FSTIR
.CTVIIM
I LIL GETEA T
.RY
ITAST JUS AEN MOMTHA TTE W
EEWKN WAD H SHUC A GDOO
RTIMPOTOTAN SRY.
USWE JTW KNE.
O>> S, THETO SRY WAS PEDLIUBSH,
RRY.
TA A MENOMT.
THSO, TOE SRY WASLI PUBEDSH
NO8,ERMB 28. 201
IT IS NR EMOVBEAY T21OD.
YRETHERSEA.
REEEARSGO A.
TD,AN A TS3 .EA YRS, AGOOU Y
WEREEI BNGREAW LYE
ETHOSAWYE AINGA,OI DNG
EV, HIYTNGINCLINUD TGHEEO VIDS
, ARMECUNTEO VYIDT TSHA
YEMILDOR WKEN O W YHIT.OU
IWHATSAP HNIPENG?
GTHMEINNEAP HPEDN OO
TH
KSGINGAY D.
>>ASLYMI WGAK MINIE TS.
AROU YNG GOI TOE MINAKGIE PS
YWITHROUIL FAMY?
THRSAW LYEE WERKI WORT IVE OR
HTHE.IDOLAY
THDAL CLEER H AND TDOLER HHE S
THADOOR REW OKNE OFHE TS.ID VEO
ROESH DEDPPVE EGTHRYIN AND SHE
EDWORERK WHE TLEHO TNGHI LEIK A
R
PEOOR.
OUOF CERSHE SDAL CLE ME
SC
GAMREINND AEL YNGLI.
TEAU[LGH
S IUS JTHA WT WEEA D.L
ISUS JTY VER CHAENGINGOR WK
ITBU ITS VYER IORTANTO T
WO
.RK
YIFOUEE KP YROU EYEN O WHA THE
GO IS, WEIN KD OFUS PH TOUHRGH
.IT
HELAL TLL CHAGES, ATSUMRGENO T
H
ERSDI ETO.
LTHEKAC OFES R.RCOUES
FTHETACT THAHE TY DO NOTAN WT
YOTO, UW, KNOAY POR FS THI OR
Y FOR TTHA.
H IARDOM S.IMETES
JYOUTUSEA DLIT WH IT LEIK A
SIOFPRESALON.
>>SO, I WLDOUE LOVOR F YOU TO
TE ES UCTXALYT WHANEAP HPEDN O
TH DAYHA TTOU YUB PSHLIED.
INO KWHA TT YOUE WERGOP HIN IT
WO A BDEPL SHAS FOR A DAY IF
U WEER LKYUC.
>>RY SHETO WASLI PUBEDSH
NEONLI.
PHE TYUTHA TTHO WLEERIES
OUENL OIN RHTIGWA AY.
ET B IT WAS AHU TDARSY.
EN WTN IEA RLAR ELYHA TTI
GRNMOINAU BECSE IW KNEHA TTT I
ULWOD LNCAUHND A WEER WEOI GNG
TOO DOM SEIA SOCLED MIAN IT.
D,AN Y KW,NO IAS WUTBS AOLYEL
X
D.USHATE
WEN BADEETI EDING IT FORKS WEE
WAND OKIORNGNHE TEO VID
.
AYOURE JTUS ATHE TOI PNT WREHE
YOUS JTANTEDO TE B A OLLR.VE
YOAN WT TO GOOM H ANDO GO T
D.
THHAU LNCIM TES FORHE TIN ONLE
S
VEFNIO OHE T SRYEP KT
CH
.GIANNG
WELYIN FALDE LANDN OEM NOVR BE28
T
0  7:0M.A.
EN WTOM HE TTHAIG NHTNA UEBL TO
EESLP.
INI FLYALOT G UPUT ABO:0 4A.0 M.
IDE HEAD TOHE T GYM ATE FIV IN
D IMCLBE TONHEIP ELLCATIL
NETRAIR.
ASI WGOP HINT IOU WLDT LAS
ON ANETEA LST ONE.AY D
IROVE TOHE TEW NOOMUS JT
AFN. DRAW
PESTI OPDND AGH BOUT BELAGSND A
HOPIAD ING HUG ENOH MEYONN I MY
BANTCC AOUO TER COVHA TT
EXE.NS
IDOO LKE ATHE TGE LARALIG DIT
SCENRE.
HE T TOPF O THEIS LTAS W A
ST
STARNDTE IOL A DRLATO SRE.
THDL HEEAASEIN WOM WANSE PASS
GA
S INTO SREIM H AND PLSUL A
IFKNE.
WITASNGET GTI TDSUSHOAN OF
TSHI.
MOI ALSTER NEVAI PD AONENTTTIO T
TOETH SESRIT THE TOPF O THE
D.BOAR
THER WEFTENCK CLIAI BTT THA
WE DOE LURRSEA RDE THE TE MOR
ITWEBSE.SISRNOUAL OMNUR O
AT:0UTBO 8A.0 M.HE T TEEHR
ORTPAS TFHESER SIE ALONGIT WH
ASETH MVESIRA GICPHS,LL A THE
DEVI,OS A TEELIMINND A AIE P
CA HEDOWE WOT GHI TS SRYTO
AUREWE L UHENCDERND THEDL HEAEIN
FUMP TRERU CINABETREM MBE
VI
LI TNGO BE AIMIF LETE.
I TETWEED O THE S.RITOES
IYAR HDLAD HNYLO FOLRSWEN O
TETWIT SROT I WAS AHO SRT
.
R OUOIA SOCLED MIAAL TTSEN
WE BUS BYGTZLIINHE TTO SESRI
HESSRO TNENT IERT UEVENIRS.
NGTCWAHIHE T SRITOEST A THEY VER
O
FOMTT O THEIS LT.
THETINT IENSON OFOI GOMNG H
E.
I WASIE RELDVE IDOR WKE WH DON
H
SR NEEWMOOASRT STAGIN TO GET
BU.
ENSUDDEN,LY RE REEÉ REEZRIODGU
OTEOUDRVE.
HE>> T OIR FSTNEAD H TDSUSHOAN
OFITS.
,LLER NEVNG GOIO T TOPT THA
RTTO SRY ID SAIKI WALNGAC BK
TOY DK.ES
FOBENI TREUR ONGFFY MTEOM CPU IR
EDLOOKT AYERWI TTT A.OUCCNT
SIYDEUDNL HAD TDSUSHOAN O
ERLLFOOWS.
TH THENB UBLIEELVAENEAP HPED.
ELIT BVEIEDHE T.TO SRY
THOO RMPT ERUED.
NE PMYHOTA SEDRTIN RNGGIN IY M
ERMPCOUTOXAI MLB WASNGIL FLI UP
I
GR CTHONIOULATAT.NS
ST FEIR CIOLEOLCTNAS WRO FM
WR.ER
REMOHA TN ETELAD.
FIEY,LL HAI SD, SEOOMNEUT P
ERGETOTHTOHE T S IRYN A WAY TTHA
OPSCOFE IS HRI CME ANDOW H THE
ECPROS HORUTS EPEELDTEPSINO T
OMT GEFRHE TM.
RDS HIWONT MSEA THEOR WLD TO ME.
USPP[ALAE]
YAV HEEEOU SNX ALE ASTCOA AT
LALTLEC RENY?
TEAU[LGHR]
>>
T ATLL A.
[L
TEGHR]
I DOOT N TNKHI TTHANY ADYBO HAS
E
, HENIM AY.UACTLL
.
WAIG SHTET,GS L'SUT P ITT THA
L S>>O,KOO.
IS SRYTOAS HNE CONIOCTNS TO
FOTWO ERRM PNTSIREDES.
TINNCOECOSON T ANC PRIE.
IT HASST PREIOIGUSTT ANEORYS ALL
OVT I.
OMD,AN CGIN UPT NEXEE WK, NT
AWEEK TERFTIVNKHASGUTG,IN B
WERTHELILE B ATHNOER TALRI.
TH IES APT CHAERN I HE,
ETHERS I AERHA CPT INHE T BKOO
ABOWTOU HS THIND EED FOR JFREFEY
P
EISTN.
IW KNOHATHA TT ISOM SHIETNG
AT
THEEO PPLSLW AAY WTAN T KWNO
OMFR
OU Y.
WHO DOU Y TNKHIPE HAPNS?
EL>> W IL, DOOT NNK THIHA TTE H
MMCOSUTEITD IDICE.
NOI KW A LOT OFPL PEOEAG DISERE
HATHWI TT.
I VE CEROVED PSONSOR F A
TLONGE.IM
I KWNOHE TAY W TTRU CORIOPTN
HAS.EN
IS W AOOEX TTB CKEASF, OOU Y
KNA SOUPIUSCIS.EA DTH
THWEREUSTOO TAN MYES HOL
HE THO WLERY STO.
UW, KNOE H HAD JTUSOM CE OFF
OF
DEUI SCI WAT.
,KNU OWY THEOO TKHE T GUY WHO
WAELSHI CATLMEOU HRSUT O
BE THI ALLEDEGLYAP HNEPED.
HE HADWO T GRDUAS FLEE ASLP.
YOUNO KW,AY S TEAK THEY, BODG
REVE THEY BODHO WITUTVE EN
PKITANGAPTOHOGR.HS
WETHLEHOHI TNGS IOU CEDPLH WIT
THAC FTT THAPS EINTES ITE EPSIN
THS EYP TEF ONER PSO W
LIBEEEDEV HAS WVE ABOHE TAW L.
ADNOT GTE AYWAIT WHT IHE T
MET RSTI
.
A WISASNLDE. CAS
SOU CLDEEHE TLA CIMHAT
THRG CEHAESER WE BEDASN O THE
PLEAINAR BGAHA TTE HDGR AEE TO
TH SERALSE PROTOCURSN I
A.ORFLID
EFTHERE, T CRGHAESER WE
ADALREPO DYISDSE OF.
WY ONLN I PSORINOR FE LIK A
O
HEHNT WN HELL AEDEGLY
CO
DITMMTEDEUI SCI.
AS W HIRGINAW LRSYE UPNT UIL
TH
K WATEE.
OLE THWHE TNGHIUS JOE DSOT N
MA
SE SKEEN TTHAE HOU WLDAV HE
DONETO TIN BEG WH,ITUT B NOT
TONLY BT,HAUT DEON ITT AIS H
OW
D. HNAN
WTHIS A MAN WHOID D NOTO D
NGYTANHIISN O H. OWN
.... ....
BA PROYLD WOUETN' BAN TRIE.GL
IFS THA IATWH ISN IFOT RE M
BU IAN C G'TETNTRE CDE
LEID
BEME USI'OT AEWOR YK
ALIKEOREW N YKALOU JRNT ISTO
TGE CIADERENTLSEN  ITH
OUURCOTHO,SE S A IM PUS JTYIRANG
I
IL W A BLEEBLO TETN IHE T
TRCOURD,M OOANNOOU Y KW,E HOP
RFO THEES BT.
EAD ANPL IF YONEWAOE DS
NO
ASK QNSSTUEIO- -
EL>> H.LO
>>CAYOF U E LNINP UIN THE
MI.LE
A.
HA>> TOUNK YO S MH.UC
I'VEM RYPI INSY DRE BL ALOF YROU
RDHAK. WOR
MYST QUENIO IHER W YOUFR ADAI
NYOF AEA THR OTSAL RFET,TIIAON
SDAN IHE TRENYTHG VEATTH ER
ENHAPP?ED
>>ER N'MEVDFR AAIF. O
ILEMYS I KFDIN OHE T O TNETHA
MA
WS KEMEECRYOR BHESEAU S I
STH
EVOE IC OF R
SOEAN.
USBECAE IT JUS- - I DUS JT'T
THTABK OUNTT I US IILT'
POTD TEOUO TE. M
IEL TLEO PNOEPL KASIW  WTN'
WOIEDBO AUTOW N TOUTHA YRI BNG
ITP, I
AM.
[L
TEGHR]
IWHEN C WASGEROVIN TNSRI PSO
I MOFAS R RE W ARIOREDUTBOY M
FESA.TY
ABWAI S DO TLEO TOHE T SRY
R
THEAR RAD.
JE EREFFY HTEPSINID NADO EAT WHA
HE W CONNGONFRTI
YEA RLLTID DN'W. KNOHE
ONHE C HCTTAED BIM I HHI TNKE
GHTHOUTHT ISUSAS W JT SEOM
ERPORERTTHRO FM I MIE AM
RD
WANDT I SHENG GOIETO T G
OD NATOBE EYLSTAS HN'DYLR AEAH
?
ISO THANKHI TTKE WORD MO T
YFA
HARVO TTOR I WRD KEFOOT N
AALRELYMALLUT BEG A R
NL
PANEWSRPEOT "E Y NEWKOR
"METIS.
F >> IITAS WTH "ENE
TYOW RKESIM"E HOU WLDAV HE
MPAIDEOR AONENTTTIUT B I DN'IDT
WOIL UYNTFT AER TIE SHEERANS R
AND E  WHAAOU CEPL OF
ICSUSPHIUSIO TSNGAP HHIN,PE WCH
YOLLWIAV HEO T G METYOO B
D
IREAD ITNHE TOO B
K.[A
E]LAPPUS
[LTEGHR]
>>,HIULIE.
OUENC YVEEL BIE A,ND SIDO D
TH
GUE Y TTHAOYES DTREDHE T
PA TNGTI DT HAHEN'IDT CMIOMT
SUE.ID
U E ARYO TINGOG TOCKND A
ES
HWHAT IPEAPEEND A SU F  IYONCA
NDFI O?UT
D>> INO'TON KHOW W OUC MH MF
YI
UL SFEHOED ID DTOATICE  THE
Y.STOR
THSE'O SY MANTH OERESTO SRI.
YIN M MDIN THION ISS EHA T
D
BEENGO FORENTTNDRE THEAS W
SOILSTL MEUS JONCETI D I AEND
TE TOHI TNKT THA M JYOB WHIT
ORE THSTAL IYS VESTMO O ARND I
OEDNE TIN FDTH ANOE LERIK
HS
THONE ATEO PE A NOT P
IG
N NTTEIO.TO
ITEE B THRR O YOU FR
R,
ETHRE HND A ANCF ALSIIE  TOO
T
O UP SITYBMAE S I FIM TEER OORTH
PELE T LOETS UHI TUT ANKBOT. I
L WWEIL BALE TNG AUTBOS THI
DOCUIENTMEARSOI GNG ON AUTBOHO W
I
EFEDLL JPSEYFR EISINTE, Y M
THT.GH
THAN. YKOU
MYIC BASIOUE QST INS DOOU
THT TKHAEYEF JFRINPS ETEAS W
LIKMACAILI LNGES TE,HE HDEA OFBL
ATEMID HNDOW HIDE PH
T
LDHARO,EV LINHE TME FOREY MRON
R?NAMAGE
K Y>>OUHEW,NO WID IN DHE T
SEES,HE TREER WMA SEO NY
GLANESEO  TTHE. CAS
ALLHEFUOW PERLEEO PPLHA T HTE
Y AEWNDOU HNO KW, H DOWIDE
TGEIS H MEYON.
THASEER WLL AHE TSEBI RAB HTESOL
LD CIOUJUAV HE EDMPOW DN AND I
THADO AE  SDDOA O NTOI TFRTSO O
DENEHE TRY STO ANDO  DA
RTCEIENAI P OCE IT BAUECSE
THASEER WO NAY WOU I CLD D IT
O L,AL SIID DTN' R LLLEAYKOO
TINTO PTHAFTAR OT I TOE B
HO.ST
KW NOWE LWNO AOT MEUT ABO
ALATTH, HIL S CIONEONCTNS AND
HALEOP T HTEBA PROADYBL HHE TPE
ONODGOS O S TO SNDAKPE A
Y AIRTNL'SHEN IHA TTORAT CEG
E
ALRDY BNNEE OHE TOR RECD
AYAS SGIN EHA TT STEPSINDOL
NSLLMIIOF ORSOL DLAHIRO FM
M.E
EV NER RDOREPTET. I
YO RN'DOTOREPT IT B
AUECE
EIEPSTSOHAN D G THMEIN YONOU AND
ITOU Y BNO KW,EUT H I HAS FSAR
AMREMO D TINAGGNHAVEHA WTE IRT
IS
TH, EMI 50  TIOLLNT HAHE
OLSTE.
EIEPSTWAN S AOLSD GOO MT A
G
LEPEOPHEEE FL AD H AOM SHIETNG
M TONHE HR  OHEADCTON CNE
N.
ONI DW  K'TNOWHOEE DHIP S
ECCONN WONTISE ERTO SFEOM O
THEOEES PUTEPL BLKE  HTAEDUT ABO
IT H OROWO TGRHO PTOFHSAP OIM H
THWIF OSE THEEEO PPLND A P
E
WEALLOMS TDHEVEELS TEO BIT WH
AHIMND ITE GAV HE SIMOM
EDCRYILIBITHEHA TT WITH OER
WO HDNUL'TEAV I HADF HERE W AEE
RGURELA MLLTIULMIE,NAIOIRUT BE H
ED TSE PPLEOE TODEOM SE EEGR
TO LET GERAGVE ORN  EVEREMO
IMPEANRTT OLEOP SE H WAS A
ONODGO CAN M.
ITARDO KWNO HOWHEUC MH
RELY HADSU VERS M HOWHUC HE
EODLE PE PLTOIE BEL HEAD H.
I >> NTWA F TOSTIR TNKOU YOR F
SINBEG IH UCANTIPINSRA
TOO
I'MERHO SRTTHHA TN EUY GEF BEOR
E
R]GHAUTE
YORURE A T ALYN ITIPINSRA.ON
RTE THPAHEF O TIOO BK OV L SEDO
THCHMU, EHA CSENLLGEF ONG BEIN A
IGVEINSTREIVATE  HRTPOEROUEER Y
A
S  TVEHIORSTYND A SLL YOU
ARNGUL PLIEE TTH T GETHE
CLARTIETT WRI.EN
W WINHYARE E WE REHE WDAE ARTOY
WIAPEW NSPOSER DAVOU Y H
ST
ALCTRUURR OOU FNAATNDIO
LCNESS
INGEANS  THEBUEW NS
CTHATELLDOU HE SPAV NERSPEWAPS
RGLAE ANLSMD ALGHHR TOUHETOU T
COY?TR
>>NE IIF K S TWHENUTOLIO TO
TH W,AT IROLDOU PWIBLBAY AN
TZPULI PRI FOR TT.HA
ITS I AUC SHOU T BGHTLATE
BERE USOUTITT AENFO IONS
D
ANSO MROTY HECE PLAS NH WOWIT
ER IENTNDTNE AL OC SIA
DIA
ANDVE EG.THRYIN
ZY C'SRA
KNN'DOT T  WOWHAETHNS ARWES. I
THHILYON T INGAN CAY S IS I
THLEPEK OP WTI SLLTAN TOEA RD
O
RI SODTO G AESNDOO T
JO
SMNAURLI
TON D'THANKHI TL WTIL GOY. AWA
GHU YOMI GTETHE TINEA HDL
T
INTURNHEONG  T TV,OUUT B YE'R
INT NOGOTOG  GETOO A GYSTD OR
IT OUOFANT DF OE OU CRSLALF O
YOARE ECREHE BOUSEAU Y ARE
SADREER SO I PREHIACNGO THE T
HOICHROUEER YBLRO PBA
DERSNDTA AT, TLLHA T AREHE'S
WHER OETHAR PT OHEF T OOR WLDF
LEPEOP JHA TTTUSON D'TEA R
D.TH
EYEA RYLL D'TON.
UREYTH TN ONV TND A HR
METHOMG INFRHAEA SN ITNNYND A
INTHKT' THAS AED BLLASCTN  OFA
ANATTH'S A TLLHE STO.
ORND ASOERN CPEOOR,EV WHOR YEROU
RSPE ISIUAONS, BUT ITOESH BOT
A
.YS
A IISS WOR WLDREHE IHI TNK
EDOUR NATUCIOM YS STE HALRELYAS
OTO D ATE BET. JROB
IHI TNK TT'HAS WTREHE IS,TA SRT
WIDUUR O E STICAONTEYSM.
>>NKS.
.EL HLO
ILTEAIT WH OFERHE T HD ALAEW F
YE SBAS CK NITO 'SOEIC TEE S
ANHEROR REPR.
VERSNSIO OF S.S U. TRITOESTHA
DAVEHA AEDPTHO S SIK LE LAYAW
DE& ORWHANR D OU'SAT YNI ORPI
N
OFT? I
INO ,VEE 'VNEN SREET. I
DON WATOT ACH LF O T
OVEHA TOR FCEFYS MELET SOMESIM
TOERCHAT CINTAHI THASNG T ATRE
NEEDEL RATSEEC BAU IW KNO
I
LDSHOUATCH TMHE'MUT B I A NOT
TGOODCH WVAT.ER
INI THK IE HAV S ATTRTHO A
N
.SPAN
[LTEGHR]
I,>> HUL J.IE
NTI EDSKO T ABO AUTOUOW H Y
GANAVIED TETHTR CONEROVSY O A
STARINY  PR CUTILACTE THFA
TH AHE TREOT ARE LF O
TOPINSRAAL TORIES GNGOICO
AOUARNDT UTBO IE CABEUSITMS SEE
I
CU DKEISINSSGERHE WTHOTR O N
EPNLE KILDLFIM HSES I
SCDI WSIUSNG HTHHEEREAS W A
GOMERNNT OGE ANTRHE TNT CLION
T
REDAT OINNY ATHE LGIKHA TTO S
HOWO D YAVOU N TATIGENDT HAKIF O
ROCONT ARSVEY HNDOWRE AOU Y AEBL
TOTHSUURE HT REIGESOU SRC
N
ERTH AEREO SAN MER OYTH
CO TINETGSORHEIEUT O T
RE?
HI I>> TNKT' ISOR IMPNTTA
YEVENER DOUO A ATO SRYAS
LIURJONA H YSTOUEAV TOE  MAKRESU
VEU YOHAHE TTS FACCKO  TBAT I UP
SO WNHEE SOMF OSE THE STOES
CO
T UMEP,SEHE CACSPONIRY
RITHEOU, ESYO JUS GOOPO  TPE
I
KE EN AERXPTT THANO KWSBO AUT
THINNEBOS  THE NIKKEC LAE
NDFRIE OFINESHA TT' A
NOLLWE-KWNHO PAT TGILOSTASTHA W
PRTEN ATINPS ETEOP A'SUT.SY
EDWOI RKIT W F HHIMRS YOREAN O
DETHE  CHSAT I IEROVEDN THE
PRYSONIS SDM TEANE HXP EINLAS
LERYVE CNLYAR IAI DETTABL OUHY W
IDHE DELT N'FETE EPSMI CINOMED
EICSUIDIKND A LIE AI SD, IAV HE
T A LOOFXP EEIEERNCINOV CER
GCR
ES A COMNMO SHISEEN TSNG
DNDI'TNAP HPEHIN I T TCAS SETHA
DWOULN.AP HPE
YOTOAV HE  TATRES THIS A A
POIANTLME CRINE SCERO FM T
HE
GNNGIINEC BOUSEAU Y GAN C'T
ABACKNDCTOL CLEVIHE T E
NCE
RAFTEGOT' IS  T ANENDDNY HEDI'T
DO TT.HA
I TNO KWT TFFSEHE O IERICSN
TH
EMSYE STRARE A TEDINOO T D
STHATO K YOUHEW,NO T
HO ST
ERANSW G ISSUEHIO T TOUISS  Y
THAVEOEASE U RRTEXL PESND A
CONS TRAPICYS ORHEIENCTBU OE YOU
FITWIK LE LEPRO OBMSIT WHT, I
O
P CUAN MTTREYH FURITE 'S
TNORU TE.
J>> IALT USRET WLYAN TO ADD
DLIJUEPESOE SOT AND LIMF O T
EN
TOO BINTAK LKTABG OULL A
THK  WEOROEATTH GO  ISNTNDISTH A
TALLHEOR REC WDSEAL TDKEBO AUT
IN DSTURTHG ISRSON CVE
I.
ETHER AREHEORSIEND AEP RTIORNG
UCKBAED APNDN THERSAW LYE
EVIREEWINRYVETHG BITOREFE 'S
HEBLPUIS
DAL TKE AOT AS  INDT'RYVE
NCHMU IHE TK BOOOW HY MANEEO PPL
DORSUNT DENDTA THE P
CERS
TWHATTOSEHE SES GOGHHR TOUO T
ENEVET GSHUB PLI.ED
>>E ON TOFHESO REA INSTID DN'
SE WT OUTOTERI AABOO BK TOU
NAJOURRSMLI O AUTBO
ME,
CIESPEOTLYAL NUTE M BITY  MEDOR
IN SPTAYIKG L IE WOU WLDTERI
INMESOTHGHEND A S SOU WLD BUT
HO Y DWID T DOUOD T HAANI S
I
T DON' JOWKN ITUSID D.
YOO EDNE TN PLEXAIWHOIDOU Y D
.THAT
TDOU N' AHI TNKS ARN JOU
T
YHOWOUOMO D S,HIETNGUSOU Y JT
DO
T. I
LALUF  OYOE HAVARAD H CRRSEE O
HEBSJO W IF SYEBOMODIG RHTOW N
OULDTO YINXP ELAO MEVE ERY
, TADEILOBU YOPROULYAB CN'LDT DO
ITHT RIG
WA AY.
WOYOU DUL TAV HEKTHO INUT ABOT I
DS A IRT STAEDNK THIBOGIN A
T
ND ADD AOGIN T IHA TTT
EDCUOCRR AO  TMEF OT L O
OE
T DON'TADEUNRS W TNDHEKORHA TT
ESGOO INT IGAESNVTIVETI
JO ALINASM S TNDHECERIACFI
STH
ATOU YE MAKTIIT WH ME AND
Y.MONE
I ITGHOUT OU WLDE BD GOO T
O
GENTATTH IO P THEEYLIUBC
AT TY TODEUNRSUS AODDJTHE T
RUST
LEGG.
HANKOUO S MORHUC FOU Y
H WRKIT TSHI BNDKOO A
OU R
AGCOUR AENDSI PER.ENSTCE
I'RESU ITOOK AFOT L O
.
CTHEACSPONIRYND A TSHI CREURE
WTHATASEF JEYFRTE EPS
AID
HEWHET HREOO TK HIS OE, LWNIF I
LFEELEIK AIG BRGETO SRYEV IS EN
RVE THPE OSIERONFTI JUS.CE
URMI' CUSIOO TNO KWHEF I T'SRE
ITOT'S NUS JLA AT SHEONP  TO S
HA ABU, IC POLGECHY ANHAR O W
I
PPT GHHAM FENROER HE.
>> ITHATS AQUOO GD ATIESONND
ATTHAS W W THELEHONEA RSO RLLEAY
H
I D TIDHERY STO B IAUECSE
DINK T'THIHA TT T IT,
ORAVEGEF THIASS CEID DNOUGHO
XPTO EIN THEKE BROTE SNYSOFM
JUEICE HNEAV I CHI TSNTOURY
DANHI I TNK I W IASN AN
INRIIERVW TGH B TOREFES
WHASIE  W ASK AEDIL SIM
ATIESONY MWE ANSR W IAS AMARQU
HOHELFU TNG YOUER GEREN
IN
EOOF P IPLN THEYS SM,TEOL PEIC
RSFIOFCEERLA, WYSE PS,RO,TOCURS
GEIFB ASNTND UDSTERAN H TOWHE
HSTSYEMASN BEE B FKERON SO
W ANGNDK ORONIN FIX
IGT.
I AMULOP HEFNG Y AOU
EROR ME.
ONRANETIIL WL DO
NOWHA TTOWE  WKN HWE, EAVO S
MUOR MEMANF IORONTI.
S MECARATE AROURE THE
EV, HEYWREW KWENOBO AUTHE T
VELELF OOL PRUEIC B
LITATY
ICPART IARULLYNGOLNVVI PPLEOEF O
R,COLOEOPLHA TTRE AOO P WR,E
NOW  KNOHEATTH T WREASON L
G
ATIMEN  WGOHETESTI ARTHD E
JO
SMNAURLIVEHE WNE P TRHE
IE
OF WCEFIRAYLDOU SND AOW N WE
TDON' DT TOHAS AH MUCNY AREMO.
W KWENO TT'THA IALNOS T HEYSWA T
YWAHA TT IT HAPNEPED.
OE  WGO AUTNDE WIL W
NLW
RVINTEHEW IEOTWITNSES DAN
E
GWILLEIV DNTFEIFREESTO SRIO  SI
INTHKT THAHA TES CTOMSEEC BAU
THTYOC SIEANS  ICHNGGI AND WE
ARE ARSTNG TFINAYLL
TADEUNRST TNDHAEEE W ND TO DO A
MT LOTOEAK ITBEUS JT USE
THLS GEIRPOER WE ORIR G.LS
YFFJEREINPS ETED IC PKEDYMESOBO
THE HHTHO TUGOD NOBDWOY UL
LI A TENO HNDEAS WHT RIG.
HEDIC PKE GHE TSELS BAUECSEE H
LTFE NODOBYOU WLDVEEL BIE
HM
DANT  THAISAR PT OFHA W
ITS
OINGOGINN HE T C.NTOURY
AVWE H I TO, HHAEOP TT IT
SANCHGEN THEROU YNG
GE ATIRAONT TNDHAHE TYIL WL
LOINT  ATHGS DFERELY.
CA>> TYON UBOKAL A TUTHE
LLRVSUEIYSCEAN SDM TEAN HOW
IROSTNGAST WND WT H HEAD
N
NDIT A WOUTHA Y HHI TNKDPEAPNE
TOIM H?
H>>EAD H A WOOLEHO R
OMF
RACAMES ASND A I UERST FDANMRO
WOPPELE WHOERE ERTHEE HAD H
S MECARAMOALSTN IRY EVEOO RM.
TH BE'ERSN EEANWF AUL LOTF O
ATECSPULOUN IOABWHT ATLD WOU
HAPE HAPD NETOHE TIL F
M.RE
WMBMEERNHES  THIRSFIT
EDPPHAENN I 200 25,6,
GYNOCHLOAS WHATN' WITT TE
IS
SODATOY VEHA WTEKIR NDF
AGFOOTADHEE  HM FROAC BKHE TN,
KGODWS WT KISH ONDF E APIT
SWA IN.
TMIAINGDY HEHAEO VIDGEOO FTA
AN'SHE TREYO  NWAOU YOU C
W WLLHO IASN THEOO FOGETA SLDTE
WE DLLEAYNO'TON KW IF HE HAD
O
HIT'SODAR T KWNOCT EXAT WLYHA
KINDF  OCOTHIOITN LD WATOUE B
AINNDTA CER ILYIN ITXI EEDST
TH FBI IAS H AT MNDYNGEE FLI I
S
IF THE DID GETINNY ATHE LGIK
THAT THEY INE ARGO TGOUR B IYT
ANSNITD  ING G'TOI C TOEOMUT O.
UNI FOMY IDN OR REPNGTI
MESOMETISIDOW H D YOUIN W
R
TRUS ANDRO APPHEHAC TASM
SUORTSEC FHI TSOR REPNGTI?
I
HADVE E INTVIEWE REDAP
SCTVIIMEEF BORHEUT B TE WSEER
THIMCTS  B HATADUSN EEAB
Y  TENHEREWEY VEROU YNG SO IEDWH
WERVTEIEPL PDEO WTHE AT
KD
TWITHINSEHO KOFD RA TA
SCTVIIMLT UYATIMELE LEHE TM
.TALK
ITWHN'AST ATNEAP HPED
EX.
TONCEYHERT STAEDNGAL TKIT, I
JULL SPEHT REDIGUT O.
HTHEYN BADEETI WAING F
TO
TLONGTEO LL THE ATO SRY IND
BESCDERIDHE T FIRTI VSTICMHO W
I
TEGOT BOYAR A B TUTHEOREFE AND
NTATTH I WVIEREWASRE INC
BLY
IOEMOTNDLNA AFUOW PERIANL D
JUWEOL FLOD THEN PAI.
ITASN'LUNT TI IOT GHEN I TAR C
SAND CHELEALDE M ANK TNDHA ME
ATTH IRO BN DKEOW B IAUECSENE KW
ATE W HADUC SAH
RESPSIBIOTYLI T TEL TLRY SHETO
N DEN I RAIBPOESNSLEAY W IHA TT
FE O L AOTSUPRF ES ARETHA TT
MONDNTME AED H IOPHA TOU IT WLD
DOHE TM JTICE
>>DWOT UL BE IRE GATOUF Y
WOD FLO CSEEM ROTH PFARECE
4.GEPA 1
>> EITPISMITOZE NHE TIOATNS
EMSYSTUSF O JCETIND AOW H
CTVISIMF OUA SEXULASL SA
LYCIPEAL THO TSERETHA AOU YNG
ORD ANPO ARERDIS DCAHA,ED SDME
ISDAN MDEATRTE BYHE TEEO PPL
THUPRE A STOSEPOD TE PROCT
EM.
EPOTNEI GWA AYIT WH HISME CRIS
E CABEUS EARNELYRYVEME ELENTF O
Y CISOETD LOALWE GM HITOY AETWA
IWITHT.
ONESOFSI,ALEGALND MALOR
WHIETCST E ERSE AIDASE VYER A
OKBRENMYS STELUF  OVAEST THA
ESPLACRAOR CPO PTEFIROT,
ONRSAL W PLTEAH,ALITOLICPE
CO
ONECNNTIS AND C ATYEBELRI
E ABOVFMESO OHE TOS MRE STACD
TENEF OHE T,AI FTHINEA TCHGS
ANACMODECR
EC IEN BE AMARN JOUISALT,
I
NELEARDF OHE TOS MTAR REWNGDI
FRTPA ORKY  MWOAS WTI WRINGND A
ESTJUICHOOR F T C WSEHOTLDOUN'
FIT FORELHE TMSS.VE
OPW FEPEM SLEEEO TECOGZENI
N STEPEITNOY ONL TEA BTHE S
M
T BUROSWA PSTBLBAY LILTI HUN,NG
TTOHEAI RNDNGSI ANGBU ASIOU YNG
WOANN DIR G.LS
ULI WO MFAD CEBSYAN O OCLTAES
NY
TOAT PH  THERU T.
BOU WLDCKATE TAED BHEY T
L
URCE F WSHOLEAIDHE T SIREMOLN
TH B D TYHE AENEFSEYSORTTNE
WH
O PDFIROTEFF O OFINPS ETE'S
ESCRIMYND A B SEOMHOF O TSE
N
MYNDWN O I WTRUSYUG THOHOHT TTHA
ATWH I WASOI DNG WASHI NOTNG
MO AHA TNHEH RASN F O ADOL
ST
Y.OR
IN MYET LIFHEEIM TEV'SRE N
ERBE
AENUROR ME EENTGE NFOD R
JO
SMNAURLI MR  OAEORTAMP IOR
NI
O ME TAYPLOLHE T RGI IEN NGVI
TOICVOE  THO TSET HEAV NE.ON
EVBEI LIATE HI TNTMOS MEN I
Y STHIORENWH WLDORVE EASSNT C
TE
CELISIENND A PNDPAROGAA,
RANSCOPINDESCI ATHIE LS EDATREEN
UTONEERNDMILL AHA TT TATHE NNIO
HO,DES ART IL WIL
BE
NAJOURTHSTLIS D HATOLF OHE TO TH
TRRCOUPOWND A PFUERLO T A.OUCCNT
ASALOU JRNETSIS WT AN CNOTPU
IDAS MTHE IS ESIISONNVEF IE W
KTHINTOHE T S HRYASEA ALREEN
TOSEEC BAUS THI W S OASNERYTO
ATTHTAS WN'IS FIND.HE
USPP[ALAE]
TH
U.K ANYO
[AUSLAE]
IBNA[IUDVE CLEONNSATRSIO